hey guys i am just it's the night that
much and I'm a little bit sick so bear
with me let's do it first up in super
crazy you won't believe it news Nintendo
is probably bringing a smash brothers
game to switch nintendo of america
president Reggie fiza may told Katie
linendoll smash is obviously one of our
best selling franchises the philosophy
that Nintendo has from a development
standpoint is that for every platform we
want to have at least one each of our
classic franchises that's going to be
one great Super Mario experience and
there's going to be great Zelda
experience so you can expect you can
anticipate at some point in the future
who knows when that all of our
franchises will be addressed we know
that the fans love these games I love
this content so stay tuned in a lot less
work that seems to suggest smash is
coming to switch next up Square Enix has
agreed to publish World War 2 FPS
battalion 1944 after around a super
successful Kickstarter earlier this
month the game raised 450 grand well
above their 142 k call develop a
bulkhead interactive said the extra
funds are helping them make a game that
will quote challenge the biggest replace
shooters in the industry Italian 1944 is
being published through squares
collective division that works with
indie studios to help with marketing
services and testing that let studios
retain creative control and brand rights
bulk had previously partnered with
square on their first puzzle game the
cheering test the studio have said that
battalion 1944 aims to capture the core
of classic multiplayer shooters while
using the most advanced industry tech I
don't know about you but I can't wait to
shirk my duties as a path fighter to try
and sleep with my career when Mass
Effect Andromeda launches after the
trophy list leaks today it looks like
I'll be rewarded for it to the entire
list of ps4 trophies has been posted on
achievement site EXO phase one of said
trophy listings suggests that if you
romance three different characters
across all your playthroughs not only
will you be rewarded with companionship
and mutual understanding they'll also be
awarded the matchmaker trophy then
there's your brother the military
fees for killing two thousand enemies
landing on alien planets and completing
strike team missions which are an
alternative to Andromeda's multiplayer
there's a bunch of other trophies for
things like completing the game on
insanity difficulty and other
time-consuming things but I don't want
to spoil anything if you are interested
you can check out the full list of
trophies in our story on gamespot Mass
Effect Andromeda launches on the 21st of
March for ps4 xbox one and pc that is
everything I've got a view today do
leave me a comment in that comment box
and head to gamespot for our torment
tides of numenera review 11 thing
someone asked me where I got this [ __ ] I
think they wanted to buy it for their
daughter I did get this from a reddit
secret santa but if you're looking for
similar shirts I can give you a site
recommendation don't want to
accidentally drop a sponsorship so find
me on Twitter down below